oh Reddit a veritable hellscape of misinformation
designed to confuse confound discourage
disheartened and deeply depress us all falling
down the proverbial Reddit rabbit hole is its
own unique brand of torture especially the
threads in the dark diet culture web so when
I tumbled into the Reddit thread titled skinny
people habits that featured over 700 comments
I knew we needed to talk hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen [Music] thank you
foreign [Music] don't forget to check out my
disclaimer in the description and hit up that
description as well for my free Hunger cushion
combo ebook so I was actually inspired to do
this video after I was on Tick Tock and I saw
a fellow die culture commentator gal Raphael
um she was sharing kind of what these skinny
Reddit users were eating in a day and I listened
to them and I thought yeah we should probably
unpack this now please note that skinny people
is not my preferred verbiage but I'm gonna use it
anyway because hey dye culture is unfortunately
our culture and this is the language that
the internet chooses to use so I'm not going
to censor that out I'm also not I repeat not
encouraging anyone to become or aspire to be
skinny chances are you've seen a lot of these
skinny person observations floating around AKA
things that others notice that folks in smaller
bodies just tend to do and my job here is to
help you understand if these tips or observations
are potential signs of a dysfunction Channel or a
healthy relationship with food in a safe science
grounded space whether or not they make a person
skinny is in most cases a moot point to me but
let's dive into these observations while I make
my kids and myself a little chickpea cookie dough
all right observation number one they socialize
by burning calories not consuming them my skinny
friend would suggest meeting up for a walk rather
than for coffee or drinks I've come to love this
and I try to do it as much as possible socializing
doesn't have to mean consuming calories as
I drink my coffee I actually kind of love
this I feel like turning walking into a hangout
actually creates a really positive association
with Movement by making it a more enjoyable
sustainable activity that we see as fun rather
than as punishment or something that we have to
do to burn calories he's a freak he's a fast girl
calories which make condense but it also helps
to Boost energy improve our mood and improve
sleep and our circadian rhythm now I don't
want to create fear around going to dinner
with friends because at the end of the day
we all need to eat and as we'll get to skinny
people they go out for dinner with friends
too but social isolation is probably one of
the biggest challenges that people face when
trying to meet health or body goals and it's
a major reason why people just don't usually
stick to their plan and unlike so many other
kind of weight loss hacks you're not really losing
out on what actually matters which in this case is
the experience of socializing so to me this
is like a win-win all around and speaking of
social Hangouts observation number two is taking
leftovers home from restaurants so she began to
realize that her thinner friend never finished
her meals when they went out she would take the
leftovers for another meal or leave some food
on her plate that she wasn't hungry enough to
eat she didn't feel obligated to enjoy all of the
food right there so many of us grew up as part of
the clean play Club you know and in a lot of cases
Clean Plate clubbers come at it from a history of
food insecurity or scarcity so if this is your
story you know it's definitely worth working
with a therapy team to unpack that so being able
to confidently pack up leftovers or leave food
on our plate May simply just be a sign of having
that early childhood food security alternatively
it may be a skinny person behavior that signifies
a healthy relationship with food where you can
honor your internal hunger cues rather than
relying on just external ones like what is on
your plate and this in turn may help people
effortlessly manage their weight that said
I feel like it's hard to suggest this as a tip
because intentionally forcing yourself to leave
food on your plate or like just eat half of it and
then pack up the other half to take home like so
many diet magazines have taught us can actually
further push us away from our true hunger cues
but I would say assuming that food security is
not an issue I invite you to ask yourself how
finishing everything on your plate is currently
serving you if waste is a concern it's worth
asking yourself if it's respecting your body
to use it kind of like a trash can alternative
when our body is saying no no I actually don't
want more this is a big topic more than I can
get into in this video but I've actually got
a cool video on filling your fullness that has
lots of great exercises for my Clean Plate
clubbers all right I'm gonna puree this up
number three eating your dinner early it seems
like a lot of healthy people eat dinner rather
early and then after that they're just done
eating for the day so it is true that late
night eating is associated with greater risk of
weight gain and there are a number of potential
reasons why this might be one our bodies are
more sensitive to insulin earlier on in the
day which means that we can break down more
glucose from food more efficiently and use it
as energy number two skipping breakfast and
eating most of our calories into the evening
tends to increase our cortisol levels while
eating earlier on can help to stabilize them
three early research suggests that eating later
on increases our hunger hormones reduces daytime
energy expenditure and favors fat storage and
for and probably most significantly most of us
aren't just eating carrot sticks in front of the
TV at 10 pm right that's It ultimately calories
are king and if you're not in a caloric Surplus
you're not going to gain weight even if you are
eating a late dinner or a bedtime snack not
to mention if you are a person who needs a
needs a snack to get a good place like myself you
gotta honor that hunger folks because a disrupted
sleep from Hunger is also associated with an
increase in appetite the next day and waking
over time what's more important is trying to
make balance hunger crushing snack choices
throughout the day including in the evening or
at night you guys know me I'm not giving up my
bedtime snack moving on to Observation number
four for getting to eat literally all my thin
friends and relatives forget to eat all the time
my dad is naturally very thin and active and all
my life he's just put bread in the toaster and
forgotten it's there he'll return hours later
in the kitchen and jovly exclaim how he's done
it again LOL okay I think what's at the core of
this observation is that skinny people maybe
aren't constantly thinking about food all day
they perhaps on average don't have that incessant
food noise or food cheddar that a lot of folks who
struggle with weight gain or their relationship
with food or both tend to have to must muscle
through every day to someone with food noise
the thought of just like forgetting to eat is
a complete impossibility I actually talk a lot
more about this in my Oceanic diary series for
some food noise can be the result of a history
with dieting and for others there may be some
kind of biological reward system disruptions going
on so this is not necessarily going to be an easy
fix for some folks that said one of the best ways
to reduce food noise is to feed yourself regularly
consistently and adequately and that means not
forgetting to eat because when we get super busy
oh geez when we get super busy at work and we
don't take the time to eat lunch what happens
when we get home like we face plant into that
family-sized bag of lays then we have dinner then
we play ketchup all night long as our body and our
mind can relax and realize how underfed it's been
and as we discussed you're probably
not going to feel like getting your
five to ten veggie servings at 10 pm so
this simply does increase the risk of
having a less varied less nutritious diet
if we want to make space in our mind for
things other than our next meal we have to
make sure that our body and mind knows that
it's coming in a reasonable time AKA
don't forget to eat let's puree again
okay number five they don't sit still this one
says simply they don't sit still they get up
move around stretch out fidget Etc so there
is actually a scientific explanation behind
this one and it's also just further proof
that you can trust your body because it's
got your back so in short our body has all of
these built-in compensatory mechanisms right
um that regulate our genetically preferred weight
and one of those regulatory mechanisms is called
neat which stands for non-exercise activity
thermogenesis so these are basically just
unstructured unplanned forms of energy expenditure
so things like fidgeting uh conscious leg tapping
spontaneous muscle contractions or just feeling
the need to like stand up for your desk and walk
around or stretch or clean or whatever anyone who
knows me knows that I am a neat Queen and not in
the Tidy sense hashtag ADHD but research suggests
that knee feet tends to be greater in thin people
compared to obese people now obviously it might
be hard to teach someone to just like fidget warm
but even just being more mindful to stand or walk
rather than sit throughout the day maybe a more
effective movement strategy than intentional
exercise because a energy expenditure induced
by knee is much larger than from exercise when
measured over the day and B we don't tend to
reward ourselves with food when we fidget or
stand up versus when we go to a one-hour boot
camp bottom line any movement is good movement
regardless of what happens on the scale number
six they don't use food as a reward yep
that's basically what she said they don't
reward themselves with food so simple and to the
point basically it is normal and healthy to have
an emotional connection with food so eating by our
emotions sometimes completely normal but we do see
greater chance of obesity and weight gain when
it becomes our primary coping mechanism because
when we use food as our reward we're putting it up
here on a pedestal we also teach ourselves and our
bodies that it's not even worthy of delicious food
or adequate food unless we've dragged ourselves
through something that we hate that's why
everybody was applauding for me at the end my guts
heart and of course that juxtaposition is
going to cause a huge dopamine Spike when you
finally do get access to delicious foods which is
basically what happened in a lot of the infamous
food addiction research and this is likely kind
of a bit of a chicken and an egg situation where
skinny people stay skinny not by using food as
rewards but they also maybe don't need to use
it as a reward because they generally may have
a more balanced neutral relationship with it
so again we need to build body trust which means
loosening the reins a bit on diet rules while also
coming up with some non-food rewards so taking
a bath getting a mani pedi with your girlfriend
watching your favorite movie buying yourself
flowers you know Etc I'm going to period of
this hopefully one more time number seven eating
mindfully food isn't a big deal they don't get
as excited over food they aren't planning their
next meal or worrying about calories they just
eat when they're hungry and when they do they
eat smaller portions and eat slowly Okay so
this pulls together a few observations that we've
already discussed here but it also draws on the
principles of mindful eating so eating mindfully
means being more present with our food which in
turn helps us better understand how food makes
us feel physically and also emotionally so some
strategies that we can kind of like mix into
our routine include eliminating distractions
slowing down and taking more time to chew our food
more thoroughly as well as periodically stopping
every few minutes or every few bites to check in
with our hunger again it can also be helpful to
bring awareness to the food that you are eating
so taking some time to like think and notice the
color and the texture and the mouth feel and The
Taste and the smell Etc basically engaging all the
senses remember that fullness is a combination
of satiety and satisfaction and mindful eating
specifically targets that satisfaction piece to
prevent overeating later on all right number eight
dry drinking a lot of coffee and forgetting to eat
observation I've noticed my skinny friends that
drink a lot of coffee and they forget to eat yeah
I knew we would eventually run into some obviously
problematic observations like I also have seen
a lot of skinny people chain smoke and forget
to eat but I'm not telling the world that that's
like a legit Health hack first of all I love my
coffee so I'm not getting on coffee and sure as I
discussed in my video on caffeine and weight loss
some research suggests that coffee might slightly
reduce appetite but the appetite suppressing
effects are short-lived in other words even if
you didn't eat as much for breakfast because you
just choked like a venti Americano you are more
than likely just gonna make up for those calories
later on in the day another research has found
no difference in calorie intake after drinking
coffee so don't get hung up on the metabolism
boosting benefits of having coffee overuse of
faux energy from caffeine in lieu of real energy
for yourselves AKA food is arguably disorderly in
my books so while skinny people might do this it
is not a healthy or sustainable tip like coffee is
life but it's not a meal observation number nine
building balanced meals whenever I make a meal
or snack I mentally check if it has protein carbs
and fat to make sure I'm fueling myself for longer
can we make my smile even bigger folks I
didn't know when Ivy's kitchen stubby when
I see one because this is straight out of the
HCC handbook obviously I've discussed this in
my sustainable weight loss video here and also
basically everywhere across my channel but using
an additive approach by balancing meals with
protein fat and fiber-ish carbs can effortlessly
support sustainable weight loss and I know this
sounds kind of counter-intuitive considering the
decades-long diet culture rhetoric that we've been
sold that suggests that you need to eat less to
weigh less which is not untrue on a calorie level
but we will never get out of scarcity mentality
if we're constantly thinking about food and we
will never not be thinking about food if we're
hungry whether that's physical hunger or emotional
hunger so adding rather than subtracting hunger
crushing compounds helps keep us Fuller longer
it helps prevent an eventual binge and it helps
to naturally Edge out some of the less nutritious
higher calorie foods that typically make weight
maintenance a lot harder and tip number 10
drinking water with meals I chug this out of
water especially at restaurants and drinking
while I'm eating fills me up a lot even when
I don't eat that much food I drink like three
glasses of water when I go out to eat it allows
food to better satiate me so this observation I
feel like can be helpful or harmful depending on
how extreme you take it first of all despite what
dye culture has taught us for many many many many
many many years if you are hungry you're probably
not thirsty you're probably hungry most of us know
the difference between those two Sensations that
said research does suggest that drinking some
water immediately before a meal can reduce calorie
consumption at that meal by temporarily stretching
the vagus nerve that makes us feel full there's
also some research on middle age and older adults
that drinking water before each meal increases
overall weight loss but research in younger people
hasn't really shown the same benefit fit and we
also don't know how well this hack Works long
term like folks don't underestimate your body's
intelligence once that water moves through your
stomach and it's absorbed and your brain realizes
you didn't eat your body will likely try to play
catch-up and it'll be pissed so I think that
having three cups of water at a restaurant is
never a bad idea most of us don't drink enough
water to begin with and I always recommend extra
water if there's alcohol involved and typically
restaurants do serve much larger portions than
we normally would need anyway so a little bit
of extra water could help us slow down and eat
more mindfully but otherwise trying to chase away
hunger all day with water and also light coffee
is disorderly yes water is important and it's key
for weight loss but we still do need to eat well
friends I hope that helped clarify some of the
most common dieting misconceptions on the world
wide web if you want some more evidence-based
weight loss tips that are actually sustainable
I got a whole video that you can watch right
here and on that note that is all that I have
for you guys today I would love to hear your
thoughts on who or what you'd like to see me
talk about next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye foreign